All right guys, so here's the example for the reactionary block trading strategy. So
you can see we had this sweep, right? And then then we had a change of corrector or
market structure shift, whatever you want to call it. And then you had this
auto block right around here and some imbalance around here, right? So usually in this case,
I would just mark out this candle as well. And as you can see, when price reacted from this level,
it created an impulsive move and left imbalance and auto block just as I explained. So you want
to take your entry from here. There you go. I want to put your stop right up there.
And that was a beautiful trade. There you go, your 10 wrist reward trade right here. Very simple guys.
So this is basically it guys. You just want to, if you want a confirmation entry. Now,
in most of the time, you might miss out the trade, okay, just because you didn't confirm it.
But the thing is that with confirmation entries, your win rate is going to increase dramatically.
All right. So I would say just go with this. I mean, there are so many strategies that I have
uploaded. You only need to master one of those. Okay, you don't want to master each and every
trading strategy. Just find one didn't strategy, just choose one trading strategy and stick to it.
Just keep on backtesting it. Okay, just build that confidence. And that's pretty much it for
this trading strategy. As you can see, I want to show you more examples, but I really want to move
to the ABCD strategy because it is a great one as well. And this one is relatively, I hope you're
clear by now. I don't think you want more examples. It's just that you just want to see a reaction
from that auto block or fair value gap that creates the simple smooth, creates fair value gap.
And then you take your entry from here. That's pretty much it. So I do hope that you
like this strategy as well. It's a very good one. So yeah, guys, see you.